يعني هدوء حذر في محيط المسجد الاقصى كما
هو في قطاع غزه بعد ليله قاسيه شاهدها
المسجد الاقصى
القدس المحتله اضافه الى عده مواقع في
الضفه الغربيه جرت فيها مواجهات مع الجيش
الاسرائيلي ادت الى اصابه جندي اسرائيلي
قربه بلده بيت امر شمال مدينه الخليل
اضافه الى احراق مركبه مستوطن وافاد الجيش
الاسرائيلي بان عده نقاط
للجيش
تعرضت لاطلاق النار تحديدا في محيط مدينه
جنين ومحيط مدينه
الخليل الجيش الاسرائيلي والقوات الخاصه
والشرطه الاسرائيليه اقتحمت مرتين المسجد
الاقصى الليله الماضيه المره الاولى عند
الساعه الواحده بعد منتصف الليل والمره
الثانيه بعد صلاه الفجر في محاوله لاخراج
المعتكفين لتامين
اقتحامات المستوطنين صباحا طيب هل من
المرجح ان يستمر هذا الوضع خلال شهر رمضان
ليس فقط خلال ايام الجمعه التي اعتادت او
خلال هذه الايام عاده من شهر رمضان ما
يحدث اشتباكات ما بين الطرفين ولكن بسبب
بانه بهذه الفتره هناك اعياد يهوديه وتكثر
فيها عاده الاقتحامات الاسرائيليه للمسجد
الاقصى
اثار حفيظه وغضب الفلسطينيين هو دعوات من
رجال دين متطرفين يهود الى تقديم القرابين
داخل ساحات المسجد الاقصى ما دفع
الفلسطينيين الى تعميم الدعوات للاعتكاف
في المسجد الاقصى في محاوله لمواجهه ومنع
والتصدي لهكذا محاولات ولكن كما هي العاده
في كل عام عاده ما يشهد المسجد الاقصى
مواجهات مع الشرطه الاسرائيليه وخاصه انها
ما تزال لا تسمح لمن هم تقل اعمارهم عن
خمسين عاما من اداء الصلاه في المسجد
الاقصى وهذا اليوم منعت الناس من الوصول
الى المصلى القبلي والى قبه الصخره لاداء
صلاه الفجر مطرهم الى ادائها على مداخل
البلده القديمه ومداخل المسجد الاقصى ايضا
من المتوقع ايضا ان تستمر هذه المواجهات
والاشتباكات بين الفلسطينيين والشرطه
الاسرائيليه طالما هناك اقتحامات في خلال
هذا الشهر الفضيل